well i don't trust red wings hold on a  minute you don't have to trust red wig  but i'm gonna go see if he's right cause  i have a feeling they might be a part of  the big three  what big three the big three white pick  three androids aliens and wizards  that's not a thing that's definitely no  it's not every time we fight we fight  one of the three so who are you fighting  now gandalf yep  how do you know about gandalf i read the  hobbit in 1937  when it first came out so you see my  point no i don't there are no wizards  dr strange is a sorcerer  a sorcerer is a wizard without a hat  think about it right i'm right i just i  just came up with that it's crazy  but look that's not the point these guys  aren't magical all right they use brute  force just like you  the incredibly annoying guy in front of  me with the staring problem i'm coming  with you no you're not